so we spent years telling you that the
left is trying to silence you and free
speech is at stake well the last three
months
have proved that right not to brag
freedom of speech has
never been under attack like it is now
media companies are shrinking in the
face of it and shrinking audiences
we are proud to say that we are moving
in the opposite direction the show is
still free this channel fox news is
still free and
this show is expanding we often don't
have enough time to get through
everything that we want to talk about in
a single hour so we're launching a
couple of new programs here
the first one starts on monday it's
going to be called tucker carlson today
it's going to air three times a week
longer discussions on topics we touch on
on this show and some deeper stuff it
comes out every monday
wednesday and friday again on fox nation
you can download the app you can sign up
for this new show launch is monday we'll
tell you more
so